new smears against Trump supporters from
the 2020 Democrats
here's mayor Pete Buda judge trashing
Christians who support the president
take a listen I'm not going to tell
other Christians how to be Christians
but I will say I cannot find any
compatibility between the way this
President conducts himself in anything
that I find in Scripture and Joe Biden
continues to try to stir up tension I'm
asking if you think Bernie Sanders is
acting Trump like and his refusal to
disavow people that may be unsavory but
that are very enthusiastic about him
well by the way there's the white
supremacists are very enthusiastic about
Trump right it's not whether they're
enthusiastic about it Dana
how dangerous are those comments by
Mayor Pete to his campaign well if
remember like who has audiences right
now is there the Democratic primary
voters and so they are aghast that
Christian evangelicals would actually
support President Trump and they can't
understand it and they constantly are
asking and writing articles over and
over again about how could this possibly
be and they won't accept the answer but
the other thing is to me well if it's
dangerous I don't know for him in the
long run but the great thing about
Christianity is that it's not for us to
judge like it's not our job there's
somebody else in charge of that so you
could just stop it at that that sentence
by saying I'm not going to tell other
Christians how to be Christians period
Jesse are those comments by Biden just
another indication that he's stuck in
2016 or like 1916 I don't like that game
that politicians play where they say you
have to disavow these people and you
have to disable it is is the Democrats
make Republicans disavow their own
people and then if you ever point out
anything on their side they act like
nothing happened but with regard to Pete
he's barking up the wrong tree he has
his own issues with Christian
compatibility that he needs to pay
attention to within his own party before
he starts pointing fingers well yeah I
think it's clear that African Americans
have a little doubt about whether they'd
vote for him based on his lifestyle but
that's not my issue my issue is when he
says that big Pearce cheon's no when he
says Christians have to
separate what they see from Trump with
Scripture Trump is the biggest crusader
for for the values that Christians hold
dear in the culture war he's the biggest
culture warrior we've had in a long time
talking about not kneeling for the flag
appointing pro-life judges
he says Merry Christmas Matt Murphy
brings that back but if you look at the
Democrats he's fighting a war against
them who were they're trying to what sue
nuns over Obamacare try to boot the
pledge out of schools and you know
partial-birth abortion so I think
Christians know Trump's not a born again
you know evangelical they see him for
what he is and they appreciate the
things he fights for not what he does in
his free time Greg you had some thoughts
on the Biden comments well yeah I mean
I've been fairly nice to him but I think
he's a pathetic dim-witted loser feeble
dolt who needs to go because that was a
fatal error of what he did what he did
was he smeared Trump supporters using
the extremists contamination ploy like
oh the white supremacist is going to be
happy so he wants you to think that
anybody that supports Trump is somehow
shares those same intentions never mind
Joe the Trump has done more for
minorities than you ever have he's done
stuff for black colleges he's done stuff
for jobs and wages and prison reform Joe
what do you do you point to Baraka you
say hey that's my black friend that's
all you do so I'm sorry when Trump
breaks records with the black vote
someone should wheel Joe out and sit and
show him the facts and then he can he
can in his stupor they can ask him for a
comment because that was garbage and I'm
chuckling over what a bunch of jackasses
Oh Geraldo I wanted to get your thoughts
on actually on Amy Klobuchar which is
also on our 20/20 radar she was getting
mocked after saying this to Hispanic
voters take a listen
in fourth grade my name was Elena I
think I need the name of Fiamma of a
minute Elena because I couldn't roll my
arse very very well and so with elem a
hiss panting or just fumbling Elena nope
where they are you know his span during
it's a great great title I just sort of
say briefly that I think that Biden in
is guilty of the of what I see very
commonly the ask a Democrat do you think
all Republicans are racism and too many
of them hesitate before they reluctantly
they were all right no so that's that's
but that in terms of the Hispanic vote I
think that this is a vote that's up for
grabs the president has in his horse
language about immigration left an
opening for the Democrats to expand that
base I urge him I talk to him personally
speak with compassion about this
population this is a population that you
can absolutely czar entrepreneurial
people faith-based people family
oriented people these people could be
Republicans as george w bush famously
said so i want the president to be much
more expansive and much kinder when it
comes to that whole border issue you can
build the damn wall i don't care about
the wall zones the big doors he says
there's gonna be a big door i I think
that the president now has a historic
opportunity to expand the Republican
Party in a way that we have not seen
since Ronald Reagan in the second term
this is this is huge and he can do it
he's just just the guy to do it
I see him working it in the African
American community I want to help him
with you know to get that language that
language to the daca students the the
DREAM Act students let's these are
people that you want to bring into the
American dream this is El sueño
dominicano is the pas de nosotros let's
let's do this if those values are shared
regardless than of nationality or
country of origin wouldn't they then be
attracted to as you were saying the
policies that have been furthered by
Trump that have resulted in for example
higher wages achieving the American
dream
faith-based judges etc
B sometimes you got a play to to a
certain crowd it doesn't take a lot
Spanish people are very open they're
very you know they love to be loved and
I don't think it's that difficult for
the president to do he's just the
personality to do it I love to be left
to okay